deep inside that nest of sensor cabling
and experimental Bolton's
is what could be the future of engine
technology when it comes to the future
of cars electrics tend to get all the
love but the internal combustion engine
has been reliably moving us around the
planet for over a century and isn't
ready to give up just yet
companies like Arkady's power in San
Diego California are working on radical
redesigns of the internal combustion
engine
it's reinventing the opposed piston
engine which could be up to 30 percent
more fuel efficient than what we have
today as well as smaller and lighter it
could power cars directly or supplement
electric motors in hybrids the most
common engine today by far is the
four-stroke they're incredibly refined
pieces of Engineering thousands of
components machined to fit and run
together one piston pulls air in and
then compresses it then you add fuel and
boom the power stroke which drives the
motion and then the exhaust so a
controlled explosion in each cylinder
once every four strokes thousands of
times a minute
Arkady's up ends all that and puts two
Pistons in each cylinder which are
pushed apart by the exploding fuel and
gas mixture so what's interesting with
this engine is it doesn't have any
valves on a valve trains everything is
contained basically within the cylinder
assembly so this is the cylinder this is
do post piston cylinder and inside the
cylinder navigate to different two
Pistons that obviously coming in
opposition with each other this isn't a
new idea but it was mostly abandoned
after about the 1940s because of
problems and getting the engines to be
clean and efficient it's taken over a
decade of hardware and computer control
development to move past that stage at
the opposed-piston two-stroke engine
while it's simple to manufacture with
fewer parts and less costly it's
actually more complicated to engineer so
in-between engine runs we can actually
come in
a little bit of a closer look while it's
not running it's safer to be here this
is the engine this one is a three
cylinder variant and those three
cylinders run vertically here one two
three inside this kind of block in the
middle everything on the top is about
air going in everything on the bottom is
about the exhaust coming out and then
everything else in this room which is
getting pretty hot is because this is a
test engine it's a development engine so
it's not in a vehicle you have to
provide everything that the vehicle
would if you look down or the labeling
on these pipes here everything from say
oil to fuel to fresh air has to come
into this room and then the exhaust has
to come out and be vented just like it
would if this was in a vehicle and
that's the next step a real vehicle now
that the basic science and research is
nearly complete the car is still around
four years out but a heavy-duty truck
for the military could come sooner
actually building engines using this
layout should be fairly straightforward
because it can be done in existing
factories even if the Trump
administration doesn't have the same
focus on fuel economy global standards
for vehicle emissions are going to
continue to tighten and new engines like
this will help automakers meet them